لذلك أعتقد أنني كنت أتوقع في بعض
النواحي أن هذا كان حالة حرب،
وبالتالي كنت أتوقع نوعًا ما
أنهم ربما سيكونون
شبابًا أو جميع أنواع
الضحايا الذين تعرفهم عبر
نطاق واسع من الضحايا  المجتمع ولكن في الواقع ما
رأيته بأغلبية ساحقة هو الأطفال وفي
أحد الأيام كنت أفكر أن هذا هو
يوم رأس السنة الجديدة وكانت هناك لحظة
نظرت فيها للتو إلى ساعتي وكانت الساعة
حوالي الثانية: في فترة ما بعد الظهر وكان لدينا
ضحايا جماعيون قادمون  في الواقع
كان ذلك من ملجأ مدرسة حيث
كان هناك قصف
وانفجار ووقعت إصابات جماعية،
ونظرت حولي في
غرفة الاستراحة حيث
يتم أخذ جميع المرضى المرضى ومن بين
الخمسة  المرضى في غرفة الجراحة، أربعة
منهم أطفال، أحدهم مصاب بإصابة
مروعة،
إصابة شظية في الدماغ، لم نكن على
قيد الحياة، ثم الأطفال الآخرون
الذين يعانون من مزيج رهيب من، كما تعلم
كسور مفتوحة، عمليات بتر جزئي مفتوحة
جروح في الصدر، تمزقات مروعة من
الشظايا إلى الصدر والرأس
والحروق، وكان ذلك
كل يوم، كما تعلم، وأنا أنظر حول
قسم الطوارئ، كان انطباعي الساحق هو
لماذا يوجد الكثير من الأطفال هنا أنا أنا
أشعر باليأس وأشعر أيضًا
بالخجل  نشعر بالخزي والصدمة لأننا
نفعل هذا مع إخواننا من البشر، فهم
لا يستطيعون التأقلم ولا توجد
القدرة على التعامل معه لأنه تم تفكيك العديد من
مرافق الرعاية الصحية